Bonjour.
Nickel.
Enchanté. Je suis Adrien.
Enchanté.
Je m'appelle Minori.
C'est joli.
Je viens de France.
Je veux être auteur de manga !
Regarde, mes dessins
Des batailles
De l'action
Regarde, un personnage loin de chez lui
C'est bien.
Tu es ici pour l'entretien ?
Oui.
Tu veux devenir auteure de manga ?
- Oui
- Moi aussi
Tu es stressée ?
Oui.
Pas moi.
Personne suivante !
- Oui !
J'y suis !
Bonjour.
Installez-vous.
Je suis Adrien.
Moi être content d'être là.
C'est pas ça. Adrien.
Nous cherchons un poste d'assistant pour un de nos auteurs.
Vous comprenez ?
Pas assistant.
Je suis auteur de manga.
Regardez. Ce sont mes planches de manga.
Ça va être numéro un.
C'est très bien.
Je suis content d'être ici, au Japon. J'ai toujours voulu être auteur de manga.
C'est mon rêve.
Regardez les batailles, les combats, les personnages, l'action.
J'aime bien les décors.
Décors ?
Pas les décors, les bagarres, les combats, regardez.
Je ne vois pas de bagarre
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est pas mes dessins !
Pardon ?
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
Je me suis trompé avec la fille.
J'ai échangé de pochette avec la fille.
Je reviens.
Je n'ai pas le temps.
Ne vous inquiétez pas.
Deux minutes.
C'est terminé.
Demain matin à dix heures, revenez.
Demain ?
C'est la dernière chance.
Demain, 10h.
Désolé.
À demain.
Elle est où ? Elle est où ?
La fille ? Où est la fille ?
Elle est partie.
Elle est... elle est partie ?
Elle est partie ! Merde, merde, merde.
C'est qui ce type...
Je suis foutu !
Oh, je suis foutu !
Oh, c'est Meguro !
Tu as dessiné Meguro. J'ai grandi là-bas.
C'est très bien fait !
Vous habitez là-bas ?
C'est Meguro ?
Mais, oui !
Ok, c'est elle là !
C'est elle qui passe par tous ces endroits !
Elle fréquente ces endroits !
Je peux y arriver !
Merci !
Ebisu.
C'est pas Meguro, c'est Ebisu ?
Merci.
Merci ! Merci !
Et bah, voilà !
Bienvenue !
Installe-toi.
Bonjour.
Je suis à la recherche de...
Je suis à la recherche d'une fille.
Je cherche...
Assis-toi !
Regardez.
Je cherche quelqu'un.
La fille. Vous la connaissez ?
C'est toi qui à dessiné ça ?
Vous l'avez vu ? La fille ?
Regarde !
- Il a dessiné le restaurant !
- La fille je cherche...
Regardez, immeuble !
Bière ? (biiru) OK !
Non, non.
Non, non, je ne veux pas boire.
Santé !
Bon, juste un alors ! Ok d'accord.
Aux Champs-Elysées...
Moi j'avais dis que depuis que je suis gamin
mon rêve c'est d'être ici de devenir mangaka au Japon.
On m'a dit "n'y vas pas"
et j'aurais du les écouter !
J'ai perdu mes dessins, je me retrouve avec vous.
- "Dessin" ?
- Voilà, oui voilà.
Je vais y aller. Merci.
Je vais vous payer maintenant les gars.
Oh, putain !
Elle est pas loin !
Excusez-moi !
Oui ?
Bonjour.
Je suis Adrien.
Je cherche Minori.
Minori habite ici ?
Comment ça ?
Je cherche Minori.
Elle a mes dessins.
Mes dessins.
Minori !
Quelqu'un veut te voir. Tu le connais ?
C'est moi, Adrien !
Ce sont tes dessins !
Les dessins de Minori.
Pochettes échangées.
Je veux les récupérer.
S'il vous plaît.
Mes dessins. S'il vous plaît.
Donne-lui sa pochette.
Je ne peux pas.
Comment ça ?
Je ne savais pas que j'avais sa pochette, je l'ai jeté.
Quoi ?
Mais pourquoi t'as fait ça ?
Vite !
J'ai paniqué hier, j'ai pas eu le courage d'aller au rendez-vous avec l'éditeur.
J'ai abandonné et j'ai jeté les dessins.
Tu as abandonné ?
C'est quand vous voulez.
Si on abandonne, on arrive à rien dans la vie.
Ne gâche pas ton talent.
Pourquoi ne m'en as-tu pas parlé ?
Mes dessins, je veux les récupérer.
Les dessins.
Dans la poubelle.
Vous avez jeté mes dessins ?
Désolé. Je suis désolée.
Je suis désolée.
C'est foutu.
Vous avez du papier ?
Papier !
Du papier et un stylo !
Fais quelque chose. C'est toi qui a jeté ses dessins.
Mais je ne sais pas quoi faire.
Tu vas faire tout ton possible et aider ce jeune homme.
On dessine ensemble ?
Dessiner ensemble ? Équipe ?
Je vais faire de mon mieux ! Une équipe !
C'est parti !
Les personnages sont ici devant un temple
avec beaucoup d'arbres.
Les doigts...
Désolé.
Je suis con.
Pardonnez-moi.
Désolé.
Merci.
Est-ce que c'est bien ?
Je crois, oui.
Qu'est ce que t'en penses ?
Ouais.
Oui, c'est bien !
Merde ! On y va !
Je dois me changer.
12 minutes.
Comment on fait ? C'est pas possible !
- Je suis désolée !
- C'est impossible !
Si vous partez maintenant, vous pouvez y arriver.
Un vélo ?
C'est le plus rapide.
Minori va guider, elle connait le chemin.
C'est pour moi ?
C'est pas possible !
Tu peux le faire.
Ah elle vient ? Ok, très bien.
On y va !
Merci beaucoup !
Bonne chance !
Je vais où ? Je vais où ?!
Sur la gauche !
Là ?
Par là !
- Par ici !
- À droite ?
On peut le faire !
Vite !
Par là.
Oui, j'arrive !
Vite, vite, vite !
On y est. Bonne chance.
Viens.
Non, c'est ton manga.
C'est notre manga.
Viens !
Vas y, tu es déjà en retard.
Je suis désolée pour le retard.
Qui est-ce ?
On est une équipe.
Une équipe.
S'il vous plaît.
Bon... d'accord.
Elle a fait les décors.
J'ai fait les personnages, on a fait l'histoire ensemble.
Depuis quand travaillez-vous ensemble ?
Ce matin.
Depuis ce matin ? Vraiment ?
- Oui.
- Et ces planches, vous les avez faites...
Ce matin.